Trascrizione: Martina Piras
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
In un clima che cambia,
possono le nostre azioni mitigare
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico?
Possiamo in qualche modo evitare di
arrivare ad un disastro ambientale?
Come possiamo salvaguardare l’ambiente?
Ecco, queste sono alcune delle domande
a cui vorrei ora, in pochi minuti,
provare a vedere insieme a voi
come dare delle risposte.
Come sappiamo tutti,
il clima non si tocca, non si vede,
ma il clima si percepisce,
in particolare, tutti noi percepiamo
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico.
Assistiamo sempre più frequentemente
a continue variazioni
in termini di frequenza, di intensità,
di distribuzione spaziale e temporale
delle variazioni meteorologiche
e delle condizioni climatiche.
A queste variazioni conseguono,
lo sappiamo bene purtroppo,
notevoli disastri,
che spesso comportano danni
a cose e a persone.
Questo ci fa capire che ormai
non possiamo più aspettare.
Non possiamo più far finta di niente.
Dobbiamo provare a invertire la tendenza.
Dobbiamo evitare di arrivare a quello
che viene definito punto di non ritorno.
Il punto di non ritorno
sarebbe il momento in cui
qualunque azione
noi volessimo mettere in campo,
Queste azioni non riuscirebbero a limitare
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico.
Dobbiamo arrivare ad arrivare
a questo punto.
Come tutti noi sappiamo,
l’aumento di temperatura comporta prima
di tutto lo scioglimento dei ghiacciai,
con la formazione di notevoli deflussi,
la formazione di processi di inondazione.
E questo da una parte.
Ma dall’altra parte,
in altre regioni della nostra Terra,
assistiamo ad eventi siccitosi,
soprattutto nelle aree del Mediterraneo.
Allora, questa potrebbe essere una
contraddizione nei termini,
nel senso che lo stesso fenomeno porta
a due conseguenze nettamente opposte.
Però, questa contraddizione
la possiamo comprendere
se ci rendiamo conto come
il cambiamento climatico
influenza il ciclo dell’acqua,
ciclo dell’acqua che tutti noi
abbiamo studiato a scuola.
Ci ricordiamo che l’acqua
evapora dal suolo,
dai corpi idrici,
quindi dai fiumi, dai mari,
ritorna sotto forma
di pioggia e neve.
E poi abbiamo la formazione
di deflussi superficiali
e l’acqua si infiltra nel sottosuolo,
ritornando di nuovo
nel corpo idrico ricettore
quindi nei fiumi, nei mari,
e ricomincia il ciclo.
Ora, il cambiamento climatico ha alterato
l’equilibrio di questi processi,
esaltando alcuni di essi
rispetto ad altri.
Ad esempio,
la maggiore evapotraspirazione
dai suoli determina poi la siccità.
L’aria calda determina
maggiore vapore acqueo
e quindi formazione di eventi
di elevata intensità
e anche breve durata,
a cui consegue la formazione
di deflussi idrici,
deflussi di acqua intensi.
L’uomo ha esercitato una notevole
influenza su tutti questi fenomeni
e questo è anche riportato dal report
dell’International Panel Climate Change,
che dimostra come
da una parte l’urbanizzazione,
dall’altra l’uso di mezzi di trasporto
a combustibile fossile,
dall’altra il sempre più frequente
accadimento di incendi boschivi
per qualsiasi ragione,
per qualsiasi motivo che tutti sappiamo.
Però questo comporta l’emissione di
CO2 in atmosfera da una parte,
ma dall’altra anche la riduzione
della copertura vegetale.
Le attività produttive dell’uomo,
sappiamo tutti,
contribuiscono all’emissione di gas serra.
Focalizzando l’attenzione al caso
dell’urbanizzazione,
questo è l’elemento
a cui vorrei dare maggior attenzione
perché questo influenza maggiormente
l’entità del deflusso idrico,
cioè del deflusso dell’acqua.
Io insegno idraulica all’università,
e per questo mi interesso maggiormente
agli aspetti idrodinamici,
cioè dei processi di interazione
dell’acqua con l’ambiente.
L’urbanizzazione cosa comporta?
Comporta innanzitutto
l’impermeabilizzazione dei suoli,
quindi la diminuzione della quantità
di acqua che arriva nel sottosuolo
e l’aumento, conseguentemente,
dell’acqua che defluisce in superficie.
Questo porta spesso
a inefficienza delle canalizzazioni,
sia superficiali che sotterranee,
oltre che il trasporto anche
di materiale spesso inquinante,
alla fine, nei corpi idrici ricettori,
quindi nei fiumi e nei mari.
Allora tutto questo porta
a una depauperazione
degli habitat naturali
e un disequilibrio degli ecosistemi.
Altra conseguenza è che il maggiore
deflusso, la minore copertura vegetale
comporta maggiori processi erosivi nelle
aree limitrofe ai corsi d'acqua.
Uno sbilancio anche
di materiale solido che arriva alla foce
e che arriva alle coste,
contribuendo all’arretramento
della linea di costa.
Allora cosa dobbiamo fare noi?
Cosa possiamo fare?
Dobbiamo mettere in atto
azioni atte a mitigare,
a diminuire i fenomeni
che abbiamo appena detto.
Azioni che devono essere azioni
di mitigazione da una parte,
ma di adattamento dall’altra.
Ad esempio, dobbiamo procedere
a effettuare azioni
che mitighino l’effetto serra.
Dall’altra, per esempio,
azioni di adattamento
al cambiamento climatico
delle nostre attività produttive,
delle attività dell’uomo.
Questo si può mettere in atto,
per esempio, con l’uso sostenibile
delle risorse naturali,
per esempio per la produzione di energia.
L’uso di risorse rinnovabili:
sole, acqua, vento.
O con l’uso sostenibile
delle risorse idriche,
tenendo conto dell’equilibrio ecologico
sia per l’acqua di deflusso superficiale
che per il deflusso sotterraneo.
Mettere in atto,
utilizzare dei protocolli specifici
mirati alla riduzione dell’inquinamento
del sistema aria-acqua-suolo.
L’insieme di tutte queste azioni
hanno ripercussioni nel sociale,
hanno ripercussioni nella società,
nella nostre attività produttive.
E allora capiamo come ognuno di noi
è deputato a dare un proprio contributo,
perché tutto si ripercuote
nella nostra collettività.
Dall’altra parte, dobbiamo
mettere in atto anche azioni
che consentano di sviluppare
tecnologie innovative,
mirate da una parte alla protezione
delle risorse naturali e idriche,
dall’altra, alla protezione
e il ripristino della biodiversità.
Dobbiamo conservare
gli habitat naturali e le specie.
Queste azioni hanno una notevole
ripercussione nel settore ambientale,
a cui anche noi siamo deputati
a dare un contributo.
Allora l’insieme delle azioni
che interessano il sociale
e l’insieme delle azioni
che interessano l’ambientale
fanno sì che riusciamo
a identificare delle metodologie
per attenuare gli effetti
del cambiamento climatico
e arrivare a quella
che viene definita transizione ecologica.
Nell’ambito della mia ricerca,
che svolgo in collaborazione
anche con altre università straniere
a livello internazionale,
con l’obiettivo di dare
delle risposte a tutto questo,
ho focalizzato l’attenzione
sull’ambiente fluviale.
Mi sono affacciata all’ambiente fluviale
già da più di venticinque anni,
quasi trent’anni ormai,
quando cominciai
a fare il dottorato in Canada,
e ho avuto un bravissimo maestro,
che è stato per me maestro non solo
scientifico, ma anche maestro di vita.
E da lì mi sono appassionata e ho
continuato la mia attività di ricerca
nel settore ambientale e soprattutto
nell’ambito dei corpi idrici fluviali.
Il fiume rappresenta l'elemento del
territorio che consente di coniugare
esigenze da una parte ambientali
e di controllo del rischio idraulico,
e quindi azioni nel settore ambientale,
ma coniuga anche esigenze nel settore
del turismo e delle attività produttive.
e quindi che hanno a che fare con il
settore sociale e con la collettività.
In particolare, nell’ambito
delle ricerche portate avanti
abbiamo identificato
delle metodologie innovative
che consentono di valutare
le cosiddette aree di tutela,
fasce di tutela del corso d’acqua,
che non sono altro che delle aree
cosiddette di competenza del corso d’acqua
cioè entro cui il corso d’acqua
può espandersi, può evolversi,
può cambiare l’assetto liberamente,
ma in cui non dev’esserci
nessuna interferenza umana.
Dobbiamo lasciare libere queste aree
affinché il corso d’acqua
possa evolversi spontaneamente.
Il corso d’acqua naturale rappresenta
un elemento che si evolve spontaneamente
al variare delle condizioni
di deflusso dell’acqua,
del flusso idrico,
in modo tale da portarsi
a una nuova configurazione di equilibrio.
Tende a raggiungere sempre una propria
configurazione di equilibrio,
che quindi è una condizione
di equilibrio dinamico,
che va variando al variare
delle condizioni del flusso d’acqua,
e va modificando il proprio assetto.
Nel momento in cui l’uomo ha tentato
di costringere l’evoluzione spontanea
del corso d’acqua,
ecco che esso tende
a riprendere i propri spazi.
E così abbiamo l’esondazione
nelle aree limitrofe dello stesso
quindi dobbiamo lasciare queste aree
libere, competenti al corso d’acqua.
La valutazione di queste aree non deve
prescindere dalla conoscenza dei processi
di interazione tra l’idrodinamica,
cioè i processi inerenti all’acqua stessa,
e i processi inerenti agli ecosistemi,
quindi la flora e la fauna.
L’importanza della flora,
e quindi della copertura vegetale,
è stata rilevata in particolare da
nostri studi, come vedete in questa foto.
In particolare,
i nostri studi hanno rilevato
che la variazione e la modifica
dell’assetto planimetrico
del corso d’acqua,
che in questa foto
è identificata dalle linee verdi,
è strettamente correlata alla variazione
nel tempo della copertura vegetale,
cioè delle tipologie di specie vegetali
che permangono nelle aree limitrofe
al corso d’acqua stesso.
Allora significa che le specie vegetali
e il grado di sopravvivenza
delle specie vegetali
alla variazione del deflusso idrico
rappresenta un indicatore biologico
del rischio idraulico.
Per quanto riguarda la fauna,
anche la fauna è strettamente importante
nei processi predittivi.
In particolare, nell’ambito
di un progetto di ricerca nazionale
in collaborazione col CNR
e altre università italiane,
è stato possibile
mettere a punto e verificare
l’esistenza di bio-sensori che consentono
di identificare e trasmettere
le interazioni mutue tra l’idrodinamica,
quindi, abbiamo detto, i processi
strettamente inerenti all’acqua,
e la risposta delle comunità biotiche,
quindi delle comunità ivi presenti.
Quindi significa che,
come rispondono le comunità biotiche,
anche questi possono essere indicatori
delle condizioni di rischio idraulico,
ma anche delle condizioni
di degrado ambientale.
Questo è stato verificato in particolare
analizzando la risposta in laboratorio.
Come vedete, sono io lì
che guardo la risposta di alcune
comunità biotiche in laboratorio,
e abbiamo visto una stretta relazione
con le variazioni del deflusso idrico.
I dati vengono trasmessi in remoto e, come
vedete, l’alimentazione di questo sistema
dev’essere fatta anche
utilizzando risorse rinnovabili.
Si è utilizzata un’installazione
a pannelli fotovoltaici.
A questo proposito,
nell’ambito di uno spin off accademico
di cui sono cofondatore insieme
all’ingegnere Giuseppe Ragonese,
abbiamo anche messo a punto
una metodologia innovativa,
che è anche oggetto di brevetto,
che consente di identificare e localizzare
eventuali anomalie
presenti nei pannelli fotovoltaici
in real time e in remoto.
Questo è molto importante,
perché la presenza di alcune anomalie o
malfunzionamenti ai pannelli fotovoltaici
determina una diminuzione
nella produzione di energia
spesso dell’ordine anche del 30% annuo,
con un’incidenza non solo di produzione
di energia elettrica sempre minore,
ma anche un’incidenza dei costi evidente.
Questo sistema consente di mantenere
pressoché costante la produzione di
energia nel tempo, oltre che aumentare
la durata dei pannelli fotovoltaici.
Allora in definitiva, sulla base di quello
che abbiamo detto, possiamo dire che
possiamo mettere in atto delle azioni
che consentono di limitare
l’effetto del cambiamento climatico
ma dobbiamo essere tutti,
e dobbiamo collaborare tutti
per realizzare questo obiettivo.
Prendendo spunto da una frase di Confucio:
“Più ruscelli uniti formano un fiume;
più fili insieme congiunti
formano una corda;
essa non si può rompere che a stento”.
Rimanendo sempre nell’ambito fluviale,
mi è piaciuta anche l’osservazione
di Stefano Benni, da cui prendo spunto:
Come abbiamo visto, un fiume
può deviare la propria direzione.
Perché un fiume prende il suo corso come
abbiamo detto, il suo corso spontaneo,
e a volte può anche andare alla
deriva in acque torbide.
Ma a un certo punto, l’acqua poi
diventa limpida, il torrente scorre
e tutto torna trasparente.
Questo lo possiamo fare
mettendo in atto queste azioni.
Grazie dell'attenzione.